salut vous savez ce qui se passe je
tiens la caméra à la main ça veut dire
qu'il va se passer quelque chose de
particulier aujourd'hui je suis dans le
bureau évidemment mais je suis pas tout
seul il ya un pote qui est passé me voir
il y en a peut-être qui connaît ce pote
c'est mehdi m'a dit il est passé à la
maison était bon de voir la carène
colombo zidane a été très bien merci à
vous avez l'occasion allez-y c'est
génial les vingt balles comme prévu
immédiat et là on discutait et puis je
pense à la vidéo que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui donc hier pour vous et je
viens de lui proposer qu'on fasse une
mise en application de tout ce que j'ai
expliqué hier sur lui directement et tu
as dit j'ai peur on va pas la faire chez
moi on va la faire dans un bureau pour
ceux qui savent et ceux qui savent pas
que j'ai une société avec deux autres
personnes
s'appelle charles oxman et on a des
nouveaux locaux est on va aller la
tournée dans les nouveaux locaux comme
ça je vais vous faire visiter ça marche
on vous emmène
attention à la déco ça peut vous piquer
les yeux pour l'instant j'ai juste mis à
rêver
j'ai mis un vigile armé ici on a remis
un mehdi ici ils auront toujours
plusieurs personnes ici dans cette pièce
là on a mis un éléphant à l'éléphant
démonter tout à fait ce sont les
toilettes je pense que tout le monde est
intéressé par mes toilettes
franchement c'est la pièce principale
ces médicaments fait toutes les
peintures vraiment envoyé voici le point
des vidéos d'ailleurs il était sur
youtube avant youtube et sur ce que veut
dire c'est lui qui à la chaîne avec
toutes les formes bizarres et les
chinois mais ça paraît visant à rien
qu'à l'entendre il ya une chaîne sur
youtube tous les jours ou même plusieurs
fois par jour il ya une vidéo et la
vidéo c'est toujours avec des sons
bizarres et des formes bizarres il y en
a pas deux identiques
moi j'avais vu ça dans un taux que ça
toujours des titres chelou tu vas faire
grève dans un top 2 je sais plus qui
mais je sais que quelqu'un ait fait un
double-échec bizarre je crois que je
crois à vérifier parce que là je dis
peut-être gains je crois que c'est un
test en fait pour tester les algorithmes
et citi ont réduit la marque
ils ont mis des années à communiquer
dessus tu vois tout le monde disait mais
c'est quoi ces les illuminati et les
abonnés et ça je trouve sa raison il ya
des gens qui regardent les joueurs mais
je suis à l'arrière les annexions machel
alors écoute qu'on va poser la caméra
ici on va se trouver un joli fond
atteint le choix à hyères pour la vidéo
des 300 abonnés je vous ai fait une
vidéo récap de la manière dont on
pouvait trouver un prénom l'extraire de
la tête de quelqu'un et si vous n'avez
pas regardé les vidéos de cette année
que vous avez juste regarder la vidéo
d'hier vous dites moi c'est ça bien sûr
c'est du blabla donc on va faire le test
sur mehdi mehdi est ce que des complices
oui voila voila j'aimerais améliorer
alors on sait pas ce qu'il fallait dire
parce que si c'était un complice il
dirait non forcément elle a donc l'idée
est la suivante je sais pas ce qu a
regarder la vidéo d'hier en en temps
réel non parce qu'elle est sortie
aujourd'hui dont il était déjà chez moi
je suis la mise en abyme
j'aimerais s'il te plaît donc que tu
penses à un prénom de quelqu'un que tu
connais quelqu'un qui existe et si
possible quelqu'un qui a un prénom de la
culture française classique ça marchera
pas j'ai pas pris la culture française
classique mais je pense que tu connais
ok donc tu es un prénom en tête et tu
penses que je le connais c'est le plus
important ponctuent le connaît ok il
faut déjà que je détermine en fait qui
est cette personne pour toi ok donc tu
me regarder dans les yeux tu ne cherches
pas mener des indices est ce que tu peux
tu approcher un petit peu regardera ce
matin pour plus parler un peu plus par
là on va même triché un peu poids super
je ne bougeais mehdi pour que vous
puissiez les regarder en main pop - tu
penses juste acquis c'est pour toi tu
cherches pas me donner demain 10 moi je
veux dire que je vais segmenter un peu
ça peut être quelqu'un de ta famille
c'est peut être quelqu'un de tes amis ça
peut être quelqu'un du travail ça peut
être ok on n'est pas là amis famille ok
je supporte assez ultra rien
ok ça marche tu regarde toujours dans
les yeux ça peut être un homme une femme
un homme une femme une fille et un
garçon d'accord ok on est plus sur
quelqu'un de plus jeune ne sais pas ça
veut dire en dessous de 30 ans est
correct laisse moi finir maire-adjoint
de ce quarantenaire des alpages france
est bon c'est toi qui es bon tu jouais
au poker mais qui n'ont toutefois jouer
alors ok je vais passer les dizaines de
cas tu connais à peu près l'âge de la
personne
ok donc ça peut être au dessus de 20 ans
au dessus de 30 ans petit 40 ans de 50
ans quand je vais faire l' inverse vous
mettre dans la trentaine la quarantaine
cinquantaine ou la soixantaine
ok il ya plein de choses et analysez
vous vous êtes guetter les amis c'est je
vous jure que on a l'impression de ne
rien faire et ils nous regardent avec un
grand sourire c'est ultra deux amis
d'enfance où on sait que quand il ya un
grand sourire c'est qu'il a quelque
chose en tête et bat vos deux étoiles la
première année de la personne qui est
d'accord tu dis stop dans ta tête quand
je me prononce la lettre tu as peut être
a b c d e f g h i j 4 elle est même au
pq est restée une vw x directeur
moi j'ai quelque chose que j'avais noté
ici si j'avais peut être simplement je
suis désabusé parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas trouvé
donc s'il trouve c'est très flippant je
vous mets la lettre à laquelle je pense
qu'elle est la première lettre du prénom
aa je te déteste ça continue je pense
que c'est une fille au fait un jeu puis
si je les dis pas non mais correct ok ça
marche et je pense que c'est tout à fait
correct
ok on continue deuxième lettre par
iphone nokia on va faire différemment
comme j'avais parlé de plusieurs
méthodes vous demande juste qu'on peut
nier les gauchers bonjour tu es ok donc
bravo ça me va bien tu pense juste à la
lettre c'est tout toi sans toi juste
impliqués on va dire qu'on je dirais la
lettre mais deuxième lettre du prénom se
fait à b c d e f g h i j k l mn je les
passais je déteste seulement ok j'ai
deux lettres donc la suite pour moi
c'est une espèce de comment dire de
déductions en fait c'est ça que j'ai
expliqué dans la vidéo j'ai avoué
qu'après il y avait un espèce de coup de
bluff final sa salle de bain avec déjà
les deux premières lettres
tu as une bonne partie des noms qui est
possible exactement et comme j'ai le la
partie de la famille
peut-être même la personne le sexe la
tranche d'âge après une espèce de
logique de jiwa scolaire est ce que tu
peux nous dire déjà acquis par rapport à
toi ma grand-mère attaquant mais ouais
donc on est bien deux générations
devraient donc renoncer mais disent
moyenne un indice culturel assez précis
j'ai une mère âgée peut-être la deuxième
lettre j'essayais de déduire le prénom
comment ça va être ta grand mère riche
tu es grand mère s'appelle aïcha et moi
j'avais enfin ali shah oui oui oui et
fort il y fera sa spéciale on s'est peut
être et santé te le laisse
soulignons très sympa essayé et c'est la
fin de ce carnet puisqu'il n'a pu tuer
ses deux enfants
je t'offre le carnet qui est finie qui
est finie dire que du coup fait les
parages ça je veux plus qu'elle était
ouvert à une chaîne cette année qui
nouvelle chaîne s'appelle l'obèse
poursuivre tout ton parcours sur la
perte de pointe et ça peut-être jal a
perdu plus de 20 kilowatts et c'est ouf
et la chaîne elle est à brandao allait à
l'ewf intéressante
merci il ya un truc que j'aime bien chez
mais dit c'est ton flotat manière
parlait-on flou je suppose qu on l'a
déjà dit en fait tu t'éloignes écoulé ok
tu as une voix de radio mars
ouais si et du coup la chaîne moi je me
suis je suis assez rapidement nous
connaissent pas encore où des fois on se
doutait mais je vous recommande d'aller
voir la chaîne je mettrais un lien ici
et je mettrai un lien dans la
description
je vous fais pas le coup de rabot des
bouts c'est important et où aller voir
aller regarder une vidéo de delobel et
vous risquez d'être surpris comme moi
mais fait juste de ça allez voir déjà
bravo à toi aussi père quand il sent
super impression mais attention c'est
bizarre vraiment vous dit sur place
c'est bizarre s'est dit dans ma tête
actuellement il sait ce que je pense
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plu n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner juste là avant de
partir ce serait cool parce que le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre dans ce rendez vous demain à 17
heures hier
ciao
voilà